la cuisine un lieu de rêve ou de
cauchemar c'est selon déjà il ya 30 ans
maurice houvion champion du rien
m'embrasser et je te donnerai un fidèle
un joli sens à notre misère et d'une à
l'opinion une pépinière avec des gens
n'est plus une excuse
la cuisine sur mesure existe je les ai
rencontrés contre les matins chagrin en
voici une claire simple aéré ont petit
déjeunent sur le bar américain en
famille vient le déjeuner décontracté
fonctionnel plan de travail en granit
meubles en bois blancs enfin on aura
garde d'oublier le petit souper aux
chandelles pour les amoureux noire grise
et blanche
ambiance high tech touch of class l'on
parle ont bien vite des choses qui
fâchent une cuisine intégrée vous qui
fera entre 30000 et 200 mille francs
selon vos goûts et vos moyens